we were in japan walking into a
bilateral meeting with prime minister
abe
and the president who has every reason
to be focused on the meeting in front of
him
and not concerned about you know my
feelings or where i am stops and says
hold on
he turns he looks me straight in the eye
and he said sarah the only reason they
come after you
is because you're good at your job the
job of a white house press secretary
tends to be a revolving door of
appointees
bill clinton had five george w bush had
four barack obama had three
and president trump is now on his fifth
if you count anthony scaramucci
while scaramucci was only there for 11
days and his predecessor sean spicer was
there for 182 days
the president found his stride with
sarah huckabee sanders who held the job
just shy of two years
sarah joined the white house as deputy
press secretary which put her in many
circumstances
filling in for sean spicer including
during the controversial dismissal of
james comey
two months after that in july 2017 she
was made white house press secretary
having been with the president for
nearly half of his term sarah worked
through a lot of events in the trump
presidency like the denuclearization
meetings between kim jong-un and
president trump which we'll discuss here
her new book is speaking for myself
faith freedom and the fight of our lives
inside the trump white house
a memoir with lots of stories and a
behind the scenes look at working
closely with the president
today we'll dive into those stories plus
how donald trump and sarah's father mike
huckabee former governor and republican
presidential candidate
are different and how they're the same
if we should remove cameras from white
house press briefings altogether
and the challenges the president's
unpolished style often creates for a
press secretary
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special just a reminder
we'll be doing some bonus questions at
the end with sarah the only way to get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member head on over to
dailywire.com become a member you'll
have access to all of the full
conversations with
every one of our awesome guests sarah
huckabee sanders thanks so much for
joining the show
yeah thanks so much for having me it's
good to be with you so why don't we
begin
with what's happening next since that
was the first question i asked you off
the air so
there was a lot of speculation when you
left the trump administration that you'd
be running for governor of arkansas so
that's a thing correct
definitely very serious about it right
now my focus is 2020.
i want to help the president get
reelected i'd love to make sure that
the republicans hold the senate i'd love
to see us take back the house and never
utter the word speaker pelosi again
so i'm putting all my energy and focus
right now into 2020
after that i'll make a decision about
2022 but definitely very serious about
running so let's talk about the dynamics
of the 2020 race we'll start with that
then we'll get into sort of your
experiences at the white house and
and all the rest you talk about all this
in your book uh that just came out
speaking for myself so let's let's talk
about uh the 2020 race obviously
one of the big areas of contention is
president trump's personality joe biden
has tried to make this solely and
completely about president trump's
personality
the suggestion is that joe biden of
course is captain empathy or as
president trump is
mean cruel orange bad man uh and uh and
it seems to be working by polling data
at least
thus far up until we'll see how the
supreme court stuff plays out
so knowing the president what do you
make of that particular contrast well
i think there's a couple things one i a
lot of times i will tell people to
look at the substance over the style you
may not like
the way that the president addresses
every issue
or how he interacts with people but
he's delivered on the things that he set
out to do i think the court's been
a huge one and certainly going to be a
big focus
over the last little over a month that
we have leading up to the election
he's already put two supreme court
justices in
more than 200 justices around the
country
i think that'll be one of the
president's biggest and most lasting
legacies
and one of the areas of substance that i
point to with the president historic
trade deals the defeat of isis
tax cuts he's governed as a true
conservative and so i always point
people
to the substance of who he is i also got
to see
that empathetic side from the president
i spent almost every single day with him
for two and a half years
in the white house and he was the person
when
liberal women were attacking me and
trying to
attack my family over everything from my
hair and my makeup my fitness to be a
parent even my ability to bake a pie
it was the president who empowered me
and defended me and gave me confidence
to keep fighting
and so i i try to show that other side
particularly in my book but
every day i want people to know the
donald trump that i got to know
let's talk about the sort of gap between
the policy and the and the personality
so
you know as an outsider and i don't i've
never met the president uh
there seems to be a pretty wide gap and
americans seem to perceive this that you
know president trump is a showman he
says a lot of things
many many things and uh and those very
often contrast with a lot of the
policies as you've as you've said
so you had the job of trying to rectify
these two things in public as the press
secretary so
how did you how did you balance that
because i mean we could see
from outside that sometimes he would say
one thing and then you would repeat it
and then 24 hours later he would he
would move in another direction so
how exactly did you hold all of that
together uh i mean it's some days it was
not always
easy i mean but the president's job
wasn't to make my life easier it was to
do what he thought was best fighting on
behalf of the american people one of the
things i always remind people of
is that i was the spokesperson no one
elected me to anything
in that role they elected donald trump
they wanted him to be
the one to set the agenda make the
decisions certainly there were moments
where i didn't agree
and i made that point to him and i had a
good enough relationship with him that i
could speak very candidly
however once the decision was made and
we were moving forward it was my job to
go out and communicate
the president's thinking and where he
was on a particular topic
at that moment so i always did the best
i could one of the things that was very
important throughout the process was
spending a lot of time with the
president
and knowing where he was knowing how his
decision may have evolved from one place
to the next
and being able to try and explain that
to the american people
despite the fact he was often at odds
with the press he still understood the
power of the press
and knew that it was important for me to
be in the room when those key decisions
were happening and to be part of that
discussion not trying to learn it all on
the back end
and so that was one of the things i was
very appreciative of the president he
took me with
him everywhere so i had a front row seat
and the ability to really be part of the
discussion as it was happening not
learning it on the back end and that i
think that made a
huge difference in my ability to to
speak on his behalf
how did you deal with the issue of
twitter so obviously you'd be in the
middle of a press conference and he'd be
live tweeting certain things
uh and uh and it seemed to me that there
had to be a certain amount of caution
that you applied when you were answering
a question because
you might not literally know what he
thought about a particular issue while i
was being asked and then the press would
get very angry you for not giving a
definitive answer right now right on the
spot
because you weren't making assumptions
about what the president thought i've
talked to dana perino on the program and
dana obviously was press secretary for
george w bush
and her suggestion was that she kind of
knew where bush was at all times and
she could sort of go ahead of him and
kind of know where he was going to be at
all times
and because president trump has so much
of a direct voice directly to the
american public it seems like that made
your job a little bit tougher certainly
there were many days
particularly early in the morning you'd
wake up at five o'clock you're talking
to morning show producers
and you think that the message of the
day is going to be one thing
and by 6 30 the president's tweeting and
the message of the day becomes something
totally different
and so you have to be able to adapt
i think one of the most important things
is to be fluid not be so
hard and fast like this is what we're
doing we have no room to like
deviate and move and being able to do
that
enabled me to be able to work with the
president very closely
and not create a lot of friction between
the two of us
so in a second i want to talk about the
precious characterization of your job
what it was supposed to be how you did
it and all of that
first we're going to talk about your
sleep quality i can always tell when i
have not slept well and you can tell
because you watch the show when i have
not slept well and that is why i need to
sleep well which is why i have a helix
sleep mattress
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or a
firm bed with helix
no more confusion no more compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine
cnn even called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on and that
time they were telling the truth just go
to helixsleep.com
ben take their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they've got a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it
but you will my sleep it's really
important to me especially because my
kids don't allow me to do much of it so
i have to be comfortable when i'm on the
mattress
helix makes that happen they're offering
up to 200 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 200 bucks
off at helixsleep.com again that's
helixsleep.com my wife and i took that
helix sleep quiz
we got our personalized mattress it's
fabulous go to helixsleep.com
so so let's talk about uh the the
press's perception of the job that you
were doing and what the job was supposed
to be so i found the press's take
on what they thought you were supposed
to be doing utterly
bizarre so they they obviously
understood when robert gibbs was press
secretary that his job was to spin on
behalf of the president they understood
that when jay carney was press secretary
his job was to spend on behalf of the
president
when you were press secretary suddenly
it became what is your personal opinion
about what it is the president is doing
and i kept making the point that
literally your personal opinion does not
matter in this job like this is it's
like being a pr spokesperson
for nike and then they ask you how you
feel about the nike brand shoes
on a specific day like that that's
literally not your job your job is to
defend the president's policies
and everybody knows that right and so
why it seemed like the press was engaged
in this this gaslighting
where their characterization of what
they wanted you to do was different than
they had ever demanded from any press
secretary that i can remember
yeah and it goes back to what i was
saying before like at the end of the day
no one voted for me my name wasn't on
the ballot my opinion wasn't what
the american people not only wanted to
hear but deserve to hear they needed to
know
what donald trump the person at the end
of the day making the decision
felt on the matter and so there was a
constant pushback of
them trying to put me into a place where
i was
giving my opinion they get very angry
when i didn't do that but they got angry
with me about a lot of things
and i think that role changed a lot
under donald trump because he does
talk so much to the press himself um
that changed the dynamic i think of you
know
the interaction between the press
secretary and the press
one of the things a lot of people miss
is they think the press secretary's only
job
is the briefing and they forget
or don't know that almost every reporter
in the country particularly those that
are assigned to cover the white house
have the press secretary's phone number
email and direct access to their office
i was talking to the press all day every
day starting from
again 4 30 5 o'clock in the morning
until midnight
every night working stories giving
information
answering their questions so even when
you're not in that briefing room
you're still constantly interacting with
the press in fact it was a lot more
productive
outside of the briefing room when you
had
people who were really trying to get
information for the story
versus people who like jim acosta
constantly trying to be the story
instead of report the story
which is really what the briefing room
became a way for
a lot of reporters to make a name for
themselves and try to have these viral
moments where they get into arguments
with the press secretary and raise their
own profile
the the purpose of it i think changed
drastically from the end of the obama
administration
to where we are now i mean i think
that's clearly true i think part of that
is obviously the allegiance of many of
the press too
a lot of the same principles that obama
held but it also had a lot to do with
with their particular hatred for trump i
mean there is a trump arrangement
syndrome in the press and combined with
the fact there are a lot of lucrative
book contracts to be got
if if you can be a jim acosta type and
ladies find you
a man who loves you like jim acosta
loves jim acosta that loves him some jim
acosta so
uh in in dealing with that i mean i i'd
suggested that
frankly i thought it would be productive
for just like with congressional
hearings the tv cameras to be out of
there
uh that it actually is is wildly
counterproductive to basically be
setting up a scenario where
we make reporters stars for asking a
question that isn't really a question
it's basically a haranguing statement
for 45 seconds why don't you agree with
me that the president is a very bad
orange man who's bad in orange
and then expect you to answer the
question do you think that future
administrations should consider
basically saying you know what we're
going to do these press con we'll do
these pressers but we're going to do
them off camera
so that you ask serious questions i
think that there could be
a scenario in which that is effective
one of the only advantages of having the
camera in the room
was that i think the american people did
get to see just how out of control the
press became
if you hadn't had the cameras i don't
think people that supported the
president would know
how bad the press had gotten
over the course of those first couple
years in office so there is i guess
maybe a little bit of a silver lining as
people got to see the truth
of jim acosta and others grand standing
in the room and giving
you know five-minute monologue speeches
before they ever got to
your question and so people would
constantly ask me why do you call
why would you even call in jim acosta
just ignore him i'm like because i want
people to know
what um you know it's really like in
that room and if the press
has the jim acosta gets to be the face
of the press
you know i can't argue with that so it's
not a bad place for us to be in i mean
as you say you dealt with a lot of these
people
off camera and you dealt with a lot of
them on camera i've noticed that you
know i
have a lot of conversation with folks on
the left that are on radio or on camera
and it's very very often it's very
different off camera people suddenly
become a lot more willing to talk they
become a lot more moderate they become a
lot more personable
did you were people the same jackasses
off camera that they were on camera in
the press room
some were um some were better some were
the same
there were definitely i think a lower
temperature from the majority of the
press
and off camera back and forth but the
hypocrisy
was just as bad let me give you an
example so
the day that the president announced i
would be leaving the white house
a group of reporters came into my office
they're like we're so sad you're leaving
like we've worked so well with you
you've been great
one reporter which i won't name names
but is crying in my office actual tears
she is a reporter on one of the major
tv networks and fast forward to the
following day
i'm sitting in my office and she pops up
and i see on the ticker tape they're
talking about me so i turned the sound
on
and she was like keep in mind less than
24 hours before she's crying in my
office telling me she's going to miss me
we've had a great working relationship
now she's on camera saying i mean it was
only a matter of time she lost all
credibility she had to go
the relationship between her and the
press was too much
um this was what needed to happen and
i'm like are you kidding me
you're literally like had tears in your
eyes yesterday and now like
i had to go so i think there was such a
intense dislike towards the president
that so often i think reporters even if
they had a good working relationship
with you at the end of the day
they hated donald trump so much more
than they could ever
like you that it wasn't going to be able
to
wash it away i mean i i wonder if the
members of the press understand that
this sort of kabuki theater that they're
constantly playing has real work
real world consequences that when you
demonize somebody day in
and day out publicly and then you're
nice to them behind closed doors that
when they go out in public they can get
accosted that obviously brings up
the situation that you had eating at a
restaurant with your family where
the proprietor of the restaurant
basically tossed you out of the
restaurant maybe you can talk about that
a little bit
sure i was in lexington virginia at the
red hen
i'd had a pretty intense work week i
drove down from dc
to meet my husband and his extended
family
at this restaurant i walk in i've been
there a couple minutes the owner comes
over and asks to speak with me
i think sure how nice she wants to say
thanks for visiting her restaurant
what i didn't realize is she actually
wanted to kick me out of her restaurant
after letting me know she thought i was
a horrible person and i didn't belong in
their community
and she asked me to leave so i said okay
and she was like frantically trying to
video me leaving i whispered to my
husband
i've been kicked out we leave what a lot
of people don't know
and i write about in my book is the
second part that my husband and i went
home and the rest of his family went to
a restaurant across the street and the
restaurant owner actually followed them
to the second restaurant gathered a
group of their friends
and protested and harassed them outside
of a second restaurant
until one of the members of my family
came out and said look
sarah's not here we actually several of
us
voted for hillary clinton we didn't even
vote for donald trump like go home
you're not helping our calls
and sarah's actually a pretty nice
person so be like great if we could have
dinner with our family
and so they eventually left but the
level of hatred
to not only kick me out but then follow
the rest of my family
and protest them at a second restaurant
where i'm not even present
i think just shows the level of
hostility and how out of control the
radical left has become
and it seems like this is now a national
problem like yeah
you were the first kind of public face
of this happening but you saw people
descend on tucker carlson's house you've
seen
people just eating at restaurants in
washington dc like normally on the
street now and you're seeing black lives
matter protesters
invade the restaurants drink people's
drinks shout at them demand that they
hold up
their fist in solidarity and all the
rest you've been around politics for a
while
where do you think this level of
animosity has come from because it is it
is something that is
elevated i mean i remember being pretty
bad during the during the bush years
with bush hitler and bush
no blood for oil and all this but this
is an entirely new level it seems to me
i've never seen anything like this and
again growing up in politics
you're used to the intensity i was
prepared going into the white house
that we would be challenged on our
policy on the president's agenda
i knew that it would be difficult and we
would have to fight back i never was
prepared for the level of personal
attacks
that would come um you know i was the
first white house press secretary in the
history of our country
to require secret service they don't
give you that just because people say
mean things it was because there were
credible threats
against me and my family that's when it
became very difficult
too as a parent i know you're a parent
and knowing that your job is directly
impacting the safety of your family
is really hard to process and makes it
hard to keep fighting at the same time
it also emboldens you to make sure that
you don't let the radical left win
that you don't let them bully you into
being afraid to be who you are
or ashamed of standing up for what you
know to be right
and so while it was difficult it was
important for us as a family to
hold our heads high and keep fighting
and keep pushing and so we've tried to
do that and tried to make sure our kids
know
to do the same so in a second i want to
ask you about your role as a powerful
woman in the trump administration how
the press
obviously do not appreciate these sorts
of things and neither do any members of
the hollywood
entertainment complex we'll get to that
in just one second but first let's talk
about your internet safety and security
your internet provider like t or comcast
they're actually allowed to store logs
of
every website you've ever visited they
can legally sell this data
to anyone so you may be thinking that
nobody's actually grabbing your data
wrong you are which is why i always use
expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your isp can't see or log what you do
online now
some of you might be wondering wait if
i'm routing all my data through a vpn
then doesn't that just mean the vpn can
see what i'm doing and log my data
instead
no you're right wonder but many vpns
claim to have a no logs policy
and they've been caught logging customer
activity not express vpn because
they use trusted server technology
they're the first major vpn provider to
engineer all of their vpn servers
to run in ram which makes it impossible
for their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of any expressvpn
customer and you don't have to take my
or expressvpn's word for it expressvpn
is so confident in their no logs claim
they even had one of the biggest
insurance firms pricewaterhousecoopers
audit their technology it is always a
good idea to protect yourself from bad
actors on the internet that can include
your isp and this is why you need
expressvpn visit expressvpn.com
right now find out how you can get three
months for free that's expr essvpn.com
expressvpn.com ben to learn more
okay so let's talk about the fact that
you're obviously a very high-ranking
woman inside the trump administration
you're very powerful person you're
likely to be if
if not the next governor of arkansas
than a chop competitor for the next
governor of arkansas
so so with all of that said it's pretty
clear that the left which is very big
into women's empowerment is not big into
all women's
empowerment their treatment of view was
obviously horrendous
uh up to and including the white house
correspondents dinner where your looks
were mocked openly and
and this was taken to be totally normal
because obviously you're a republican
what were your thoughts on that well you
know it's interesting the
the liberal women were the meanest and
nastiest all in the era of
women's empowerment which was pretty
shocking you would think even if we
could politically disagree
we could agree that it's good to see
women rising up in the ranks
i was the third woman to be white house
press secretary the very first mom to
ever hold that job
you would think that would be a point of
pride for all women but
unfortunately the radical left women
only are about women's empowerment as
long as you think like they do
talk like they do and believe in the
same things that they do
that only applies to that sector if
you're conservative woman
then they're not for the empowerment of
that side one of the
incidents that's probably one of the
most impactful for me personally during
my time at the white house
it was after an la times reporter had
mocked my appearance
in a pretty mean way so much so that
they eventually
had to retract part of the story because
it was
so hateful which as you know that is not
something they do regularly in the la
times
um it was right after the correspondence
dinner
it was just been kind of a rocky time
even like a lot of my colleagues
didn't know how to address it so just
kind of ignored bringing it up
but we were in japan walking into a
bilateral meeting with prime minister
abe
and the president who has every reason
to be focused on the meeting in front of
him
and not concerned about you know my
feelings or where i am stops and says
hold on
he turns he looks me straight in the eye
and he said sarah you're smart
you're beautiful and the only reason
they come after you is because you're
good at your job
and then in very colorful words that i
won't repeat on here he says don't let
them get you down
kind of slaps me on the shoulder and
he's like no let's get back to work and
so in that moment
he's the one that realized like i needed
encouragement it wasn't the women
um on the left that were standing up for
me but it was donald trump and to have
him as the ally and the one to empower
me certainly i think
propelled me and gave me reason to keep
fighting
um knowing he believed in me and trusted
me to carry his message
so how did you deal with the slinging
arrows on a personal level i mean
obviously
you know if you're in this space you're
you're going to get a certain amount of
that doesn't mean it doesn't hurt i mean
i think that there's this misperception
in the general public that if you spend
your life in politics and you're
attacked well that's sort of the normal
day's work
and you never feel the you never feel
the pain but obviously that's not true
so
how do you deal with that certainly
there are moments that are pretty
difficult you know when people are
saying really horrific things about you
i don't think anybody no matter how
tough they are can just completely block
it out so
there are days where it gets to you but
i try to like not
allow the distractions to take me away
from what i came there to do
and knowing that i had a family that
supported me and loved me no matter what
i had friends that did the same and
frankly out of faith that defined me
knowing that i had a god who had created
me for a specific purpose
gave me confidence to block out i didn't
need the new york times or the
washington post
or anybody else to define me i had a
creator who had already done that
knowing that and knowing who i was as a
person before i
ever stepped onto that stage or stood
behind that podium
gave me what i needed to keep going and
keep fighting
so you actually had a very long tenure
as press secretary we know that some
people did not have quite as long a
tenure as press secretary in the in the
trump administration
uh by by the calculations of our
producers you lasted for 64.09
scaramucci's
so what does it take to be able to last
that long
in a job as volatile as this one ah well
i mean i think in large part having a
good relationship with the president
made all the difference
being able to have candid conversations
with him
and feeling like i knew where he was i
mean
it wasn't always perfect certainly i had
moments where i made mistakes but
i had a good enough relationship with
him that when those moments came
we fought through it and moved on but
him trusting me
and having confidence in me to carry his
message made
a huge difference but also having a
really good team around me
and feeling like i was prepared when i
stepped out there every day
was imperative for me surviving some of
the most difficult days but i think at
the end of the day it really came down
to having
a very good and strong foundation with
the president
i also had the advantage of going second
i tell people that all the time
sean spicer had um an impossible job
on a on any day but he had to do it
before
any of the rest of us and so getting to
be his deputy i learned things that did
work and things that didn't work
and so having that six month um or a
little less than that
before i actually had the full job
helped
prepare me in a big way so uh how do you
think haley mackinnaity is doing now
that you're no longer there
i think she's doing great um i think she
is giving it back to them
as much as they give it to her and she
is tough something a lot of people may
not know
is kaylee and i both had um
we i like to say we learned from the one
of the best in the business i'm a little
biased but she actually interned for my
dad as one of her very first jobs
out of college and worked on his show at
fox and so we had a
good mentor in the early days to give us
a good foundation on how to fight back
so you mentioned that you were the first
mom to be press secretary
uh i say i'm married i have a wife who's
a doctor
and we have three children who are under
the age of seven and that means that
contrary to popular opinion uh you can't
have it all and that means that there
has to be a certain balancing act that
goes on so my wife has chosen at times
to take off work
she's chosen at times to work full-time
right now she's working per diem
um but i think you know particularly
women are put in a particular situation
because they want to spend a lot of time
with their kids where they have to
decide how to balance their life so how
did you decide how to how to make that
balance how did that balance work
some days it worked really well and
other days it didn't work quite as well
as i'd hoped
um you know we tried to engage our kids
i tried to take them with me
when i could so that they could see what
i was doing i wanted them to know
why we were making the sacrifice as a
family that we were
and when i couldn't and when i couldn't
be there in the moments that i was
able to be home i tried to be really
intentional with my kids put my phone
away
and make sure they knew even if it was
you know 10 minutes
or a full day knowing that my time
in that moment was all about them and
that they were a priority and so looking
for moments i could really have that
there are some really great stories
about my kids coming with me to work
some that ended uh
pretty poorly my son got a hold of my
phone at one point
my work phone that i'd set aside and not
locked and i was doing something with my
daughter i come back i pick it up i
realize i have like dozens of calls and
emails
and text messages from reporters like
sarah what are you saying what are you
trying to tell us and i'm like oh my
gosh what's going on
i think we're like at war or something
because i have so many missed calls
finally i find an email or there's a
tweet embedded in it
and it wasn't my bosses it was mine and
hawk my
four-year-old at the time had put a
tweet out on my official white house
account full of emojis
it was trains and stoplights and boats
and cars
thankfully it was infrastructure week so
it was perfectly our message otherwise
he would have been in a lot more trouble
but there were definitely some very
challenging mom moments
but at the same time i want my kids to
live in a country
that is as amazing as america is right
now
and it's important for us to be involved
if we want to continue to have
america hold the values that are so
important for our family
we have to fight for that it's not going
to just happen and especially now i
don't think there's ever been a time
that's more important for us to stand up
for what's right
and to be willing to make some
sacrifices um
it's one of the reasons we continue to
want to serve
at the same time one of the reasons i
left the white house is because there
are a lot of people that can be white
house press secretary
at the end of the day i'm the only one
that can be the mom to my three kids
and i wanted to take that time to spend
a lot more time with them
over the course of the next couple of
years especially before they become
teenagers and you know frankly don't
want to be seen with this in public
anymore so i'd
strike while the iron is hot and get in
some good quality time before
they're too embarrassed to be seen with
us but finding that balance is hard
but having a good partner makes a big
difference and my husband helps with
everything and keeps our family afloat
and then just looking for moments to be
intentional i think for us has
been what helped us get through how did
you meet your husband
he worked on my dad's campaign i was
actually
his boss
[Laughter]
so hr problems yeah i mean you know it
was a campaign so every good campaign
usually has at least one marriage and
my dad didn't become president that year
but i did get married and he got three
grandkids out of the deal so i tell him
all the time it worked out
in some ways but he's from kansas uh
from kansas city he'd been working for
sam brownback this was in 2008
on his presidential run and when
brownback got out of the race
he actually came out to volunteer for a
couple weeks on my dad's campaign
and never went back we hired him on the
spot
pretty quickly after he started and
shortly after we started dating and here
we are
um ten and a half years and three kids
later so what was your best days press
secretary what was your worst day as
press secretary um
my hardest day and i don't know if it
was the worst but it was definitely the
most difficult was the day of the las
vegas shooting
and knowing i would be the first voice
from the administration to speak to the
country a country that was hurting that
was grieving
and i knew that there were no words i
could offer that would provide
real comfort but that i had to come out
and do the best i could to offer
something
to a country that was hurting in the way
it was and the responsibility of that
weighed really heavily on me
so that was definitely the most
difficult day i think that i had
in the administration and the hardest um
the best day honestly we had a lot of
good days
despite all of the nastiness and all of
the negativity like i loved the people
that i worked with
and i really loved working for the
president he's a very fun
person to be around he has a bigger than
life personality
a great sense of humor and some of my
favorite moments were at the end of the
day sitting in the back dining room with
the president and one or two other
people
just visiting and hearing him tell
stories from
you know life before being president and
some of the things we had witnessed
in the white house so there were a lot
of good days one of probably the coolest
things i got to do
was um at the uk state dinner
and to meet the queen is pretty cool i
don't care who you are like that's a fun
thing to do and so
that was a big moment and the president
actually selected me
to sit at his table on the night after
for the reciprocal dinner and i sat next
to the president in prince charles
and had you know an hour and a half to
visit with him which was
pretty fun and knowing that the
president had picked me
and given me that seat when it could
have gone to any number of other
higher ranking individuals or donors or
whoever else and he picked me to have
that seat was
pretty remarkable so in a second i'm
going to ask you to take us sort of
behind the scenes and tell us how the
sausage gets made in terms of
communications policy over at the white
house
but first let's talk about the fact that
your phone is disgusting
your phone is a giant giant germ magnet
i mean you carry it everywhere and then
you put it on your face
what are you doing everyone is aware of
why you should wash your hands
but what about that third hand you never
wash your phone whatever your hands
touch gets passed to your phone which is
why you should clean your phone
with phone soap phone soap uses uvc
light and their patented and clinically
proven technology to kill 99.99
of germs like e coli salmonella and the
cold and flu virus
phone soap can sanitize and charge your
phone in as little as five minutes
phone soap is the only consumer uv
sanitizer with a 360 degree disinfectant
chamber
that uses two pieces of quartz glass to
suspend your phone
making sure that all sides are
disinfected phone soap as featured on tv
shark tank it's easy to use it fits
smartphones and cases of all sizes it
can also sanitize tv remotes keys
earbuds
credit cards and other common household
objects that actually need disinfection
don't accept cheap knockoffs phones hope
is epa registered and trusted by
healthcare professionals around the
country
with millions of satisfied customers
remember other products may claim to
sanitize 99
of germs on some parts of your phone
only phone soaps patented technology can
achieve 99.99
disinfection which is like killing 100
times more bacteria than just 99
your phone can be super gross it will
get gross over the course of the day
think about that for one second and then
go to phonesoap.com and use code shapiro
to save 15
and receive free shipping phone soap
offers a lifetime warranty on their
bulbs go to phoneso.com
remember to use the code shapiro that's
phonesoap.com today
again whenever you look at any
administration it seems like there's
just a lot of organized chaos that
basically
the sausage gets made we don't really
see how the sausage is made but
you know a sausage is being made with
this administration more than any other
because there's been so much leaking
because there's been so much heavy
intense press coverage
uh and because the president again goes
direct to consumer a lot uh it means
that there's a
widespread perception that basically
it's kind of catches catch can in the
white house how does actual
comms policy get done well because the
president
is so hands-on and enjoys speaking
with the press as well as the public so
frequently
i mean he has to be very much involved
in that decision making
but when there are things particularly
like a policy rollout where we have a
longer lead
i think it's a very traditional shop and
you build out a comms plan you execute
comms plan you build out surrogates and
talking points and
all of the things that you would find in
any normal administration
certainly take place in the trump
administration however we have a bigger
microphone in our president
than they have in in some previous um
and we use that to our advantage
sometimes it's challenging sometimes we
have to work our way through
a couple things but using the president
and letting him because any time he
speaks
we know it will be covered and so
finding the best ways to
highlight a particular message and where
we put him
in terms of a crowd or direct to camera
things like that but always involving
the president
is a big part of anything that we do in
the trump white house for communications
so one of the great frustrations for
people who
you know like trump or want to vote for
trump uh and and you see this a lot with
uh the polls even among republicans
uh is that for every tweet that is good
there's a tweet that is is not so good
there's a tweet for for all ages
for all seasons there are tweets uh and
and so there are a lot of people who
including me who have criticized the
president on these grounds uh and
uh i've said that frankly i think that
his best 2020 strategy is actually to
follow the joe biden model and go to the
basement and let joe biden be the issue
because if you look back at 2016
basically my theory is that whoever
an election is a referendum on loses and
in 2016 the great misperception is it
was going to be a referendum on
president trump instead it was
referendum on hillary nobody liked
hillary so trump ended up president
uh if joe biden is pretty obviously
trying to make this a referendum
on trump now there's a bit of an opening
because of issues i think we're going to
discuss in a moment with the supreme
court and
radicalism in the democratic party it
seems that the president might want to
actually recede a little bit
uh has there ever been any success in in
unplugging the phone um that's not
really his personality
is to let to take the back seat but i
think that
at the same time while there are some
people that would like to see him do
that
most of the people that support the
president love that he's out front and
center they love that he is the one
on the front lines every time fighting
taking the questions doing the punch
back
um and i think people find him
refreshing because he's not
a scripted robot he's not your typical
politician
it's one of the other reasons he wanted
16 not just the referendum on hillary
but they wanted somebody who would do
business different they didn't want the
status quo
and that was exactly what hillary was
offering was more of the same
they wanted somebody to come in and
shake up washington and operate
in a way that it never has before and
now he has a record of having done that
and being successful i think he should
continue to focus on the fact he's still
the disrupter
he is still the change agent he is still
the same guy
that he was in 2016 but now he actually
has a record of success
to back up how he has conducted himself
over these past four years
he set out to do a number of different
things a lot of which he has done
many of which most people said not only
would they not happen
but would have the adverse effect they
said he would absolutely crush the
economy
he built a booming economy they said
there's no way he'll get tax cuts
through
he did and got better rates than anyone
expected nobody thought he would defeat
isis nobody thought he would move the
embassy
or make any progress on peace in the
middle east and just
in the last couple of weeks he has made
significant progress more so than we've
seen in decades
historic trade deals that haven't
happened
in previous administrations and that
everybody said were impossible to get
done
he's delivered on those things so now i
think he has to continue
being who he has always been
what i found in politics anytime you try
to change somebody and make them
something other than
who they really are it never works and
people pick up on it really quickly
donald trump's not changing people know
who he is
but now he has a record of
accomplishment to back up what he's been
saying
what he's been doing i think he should
really focus on that if he can be a
little more disciplined in that message
i think it will go a long way for him in
november so speaking of that obviously
we have some debates coming up this is
going to be you know pretty momentous in
terms of the debates by the polls he's
down pretty significantly nationally
it seems a lot closer in in some of the
swing states so
the what seems to be in the offing under
even the most optimistic circumstance is
a sort of repeat of 2016 where
there's an electoral vote loss but i
mean an electoral vote victory but a
popular vote
law seems to be most of the forecasts
that are the most optimistic for
president trump which means he has some
heavy lifting to do
uh in in the debates what do you think
his debate strategy should be because
he's been focusing a lot on the fact
that joe biden is diminished which is
pretty obvious to anybody who watches
joe biden and we weren't starting from
world's highest point with joe biden in
the first place
uh and and the president's been focusing
a lot on that uh there's been rumors
he's not prepping too much
for the debates what do you think the
president ought to do with the debates
well i think in some ways the
president's been prepping every single
day it's not like
this is a new thing for him he takes
questions from reporters literally
almost every single day so he's got a
lot of muscle memory
that joe biden certainly doesn't have
because not only does he not take
questions when he does they're usually
scripted and softball questions
if the press actually pushes on biden
which i'll be shocked if they do he's
not going to have that same foundation
that
the president has because he does this
all day every day
so the idea he's not prepping um
i think he is doing some prep sessions
but i also think every day he's in
office he's doing that
one of things he has to do is what he
did
in 16 i think that's changed some of the
narrative
i think people need to be reminded of
the things that he has accomplished in
these last four years
he needs to talk about some of the areas
that right now
are front and center law and order being
one of the biggest
things up until this past week when i
think
scotus has certainly moved to the top of
the list but prior to that every poll
suggests that law and order
is top of mind for the majority of
voters particularly those
undecided voters in the middle he's the
only candidate in the race
who has credibility to talk about
standing up and fighting for law and
order he's been doing it since day one
it's not new for him so i think that has
to be
a huge contrast point that he makes with
biden and he's going to have to be
the one that holds biden's feet to the
fire because he cannot count
on the moderators to be the ones to do
that i think he's pretty good at that so
i feel
pretty safe on that front the other
thing is the economy that's certainly a
big topic
for a lot of people he should talk about
his achievements there
and what joe biden would do to the
economy to
individual taxpayers and how that's
going to impact them
personality is going to drive so much of
it
and i think the president really rises
to the moment
in these types of events and i expect
him to do that
he has to know too going in the deck is
fully stacked against him
joe biden all he has to really do is put
a couple of coherent sentences together
and they'll say oh it's the greatest
debate performance we've ever seen so he
has to be fully prepared for that
um and i think he will be you know the
the mandate for biden is remain alive
and breathing yeah and
and for the president i think he's he's
going to have to get
pretty aggressive which he likes to do
anyway um but i think he actually has
some room to run now so that brings us
to the question of the supreme court
seat so
obviously you've seen the press pushing
against the idea that the trump
shouldn't fill the seat which is absurd
or that mitch mcconnell should vote on
the seat
but it seems to me that that there is a
real opening to hit biden here and
the opening is is that the democrats
have pretty openly embraced an
incredibly radical position which is
that they want to kill the filibuster
that they want to add states in the
united states senate with 51 votes in
the senate which is insane
that they want to pack the supreme court
and effectively
lead to the dissolution of the country
because there is no circumstance under
which
many of the states in the country are
simply going to acquiesce to a federal
government with 51
of the votes in the senate basically
ramming through any unconstitutional
thing they want after having packed the
courts
seems to me the president can pretty
easily say to joe biden listen you want
to be the guy
who is return to normalcy you want to be
the guy who is non-volatile i may be
volatile personally but i'm not the one
claiming that i want to tear down the
institution of the united states senate
and the institution of the united states
supreme court so will you right here say
that you're not going to get rid of the
filibuster will you right here say
you're not going to unilaterally add
states and will you right here say that
you're not going to pack the supreme
court
i i think that would be a huge moment
for the president i think you're exactly
right
um i can tell you certainly where i'm
from in arkansas
people are not going to support just a
total overhaul and a complete
destruction of
the institution of america which is
exactly what the radical left is pushing
for
i mean look at what aoc said just this
week where she said
i hope this radicalizes you the idea
that the president fulfilling his
constitutional obligation
she hopes that that will push people to
become more radicalized i'm like
wait what is that real life did she
really say that out loud
and she did and i find that terrifying i
think every person that loves america
should be afraid
of what joe biden and the democrats
bring
should he be elected and i think the
president absolutely has to remind
people
of how far to the left the liberal mob
has gone
and who's really in charge of that party
because it's not joe biden
he's already proven he doesn't have the
ability or the willingness to stand up
to him
and so he will be completely owned and
operated
by that radical left if people don't
like that they have one choice and
that's donald trump
one of the things that i think is pretty
astonishing is how the press have
somehow tried to put the onus on
republicans for filling a supreme court
seat
again you had a rough job because your
job was to deal with these people every
single day
uh i mean we talked about sort of the
difficulty of having to deal with the
slings and arrows how difficult was it
not to
unleash on them on a regular basis from
the podium
there were definitely moments where you
have to really like almost count to ten
internally so that you don't like
uh just lose your mind and yell at them
and say are you crazy
um and there were definitely probably
more moments that i wanted to
but at the end of the day i knew that
that wasn't going to solve anything they
were hoping to push you to a place
to explode or to break and then they win
and as hard as it was i knew for myself
and for the president it was going to be
a lot better if i could
keep calm that's one of the things that
i think being a mom
probably really helped prepare me for
being press secretary is your kids are
constantly
pushing your patients and testing you as
a parent and so you get very used to
saying no a lot
repeating yourself and having extreme
patience
as a parent so that probably helped keep
me a little bit cool calm and collected
in those moments where i didn't want to
be
so when you were a kid did you know you
wanted to go into politics i mean your
dad obviously was the
the governor of arkansas and then you
ran for president and at some point did
you say
maybe i'll just like go be a
veterinarian or something yeah there
were definitely plenty of days where i
was like what am i doing i don't want
anything to do with this
crazy circus but at the same time
i actually loved politics from an early
age when most kids were going to summer
camp and
you know going to the pool i was hitting
the arkansas festival circuit passing
out flyers asking people to vote for my
dad
and i loved getting to see my state in
that way i loved getting to interact
with people
and then fast forward to once he was
actually elected
meeting people whose lives had been
changed because of things that he had
done
as governor and so getting to see that
come full circle was pretty
powerful and i loved that i got to do
that with my dad
i worked on all of his campaigns from
the time the first time he ran i was
nine
um up until you know 2016 when i was his
campaign manager when he ran for
president
so getting to do that in that way and
for somebody that i really believed in
i think propelled me to love politics as
a whole
i've worked for some amazing people john
bozeman tom cotton
president trump and so getting to do
that i think
has you know for better or worse locked
me into
a life of politics but i don't think i
would i would
change it or want to do something else
anything else would be so boring after
this
so what was the culture shift like from
working for your dad in campaigns to
working for donald trump they are very
very unalike in a great variety
of ways most obviously that your dad is
very overtly religious guy and president
trump obviously is not so what was the
shift like
um you know in some ways they're
obviously
polar opposites in terms of of
personality but
uh they both were very much a populist
message what
some of the things my dad was talking
about as far back in oa kind of main
street america forgotten men and women
was very close to what the president was
talking about in 16
um and those were pillars for both of
their campaigns so that part
um was one of the things that actually
made me want to support donald trump was
that message that was so similar to my
dad's
on style they're very very different but
they also are very much their own
person and i'll never forget one day my
dad
this was actually when i was working in
the white house but my dad had put out
a tweet that was getting quite a bit of
attention and jared kushner said to me
said i finally get it he said now i know
why you're good at your job he said
i just read back through some of your
dad's tweets he said he's got a pretty
hot twitter feed too
and i was like yeah i'm used to working
for somebody who speaks their own mind
and is not controlled by the special
interest or the donor class or anybody
else it was one of the things my dad was
always an outsider
even after having been a governor for
almost 11 years
he was never part of the establishment
and so
despite the fact they were very
different people they still sort of
operated sometimes in the same way
and you know i i liked um
that they were people who were always
their own person no matter what so
you've seen
government from sort of the state level
and also from the federal level so
what are the differences and what do you
think the role of the feds versus the
state should be because that obviously
is coming into very clear focus as the
question
for the future is the federal government
sucks up more power becomes more
centralized and has democrats threaten
to basically subsume all the states
under the rubric of the federal
government
well i think it's one of the reasons
that it's scary what's happening at the
federal government because they are
trying to impose so much on
individual states we have to make sure i
think
at no time has it been more apparent in
decades how important it is to have
strong governors and strong mayors
on the local level that are fighting
back against some of the craziness that
we
see so often the federal government
outside of the president
you get to the legislative branch is so
broken they are
so polarized that they have become
completely paralyzed
it is almost impossible to really get
things done
um where we are right now hopefully that
shifts after the election and we see
a little bit more ability to work
together but unfortunately right now
there's just no sense of
working together at the state level you
still see some of that
camaraderie and i think it's one of the
reasons governors are so important is
making sure that you have somebody there
that reflects the values that you have
because they may be
the only thing protecting you from an
out of control federal government
yeah having been sort of at the locus of
all the controversy for for several
years
do you think that the the red versus
blue divide is bridgeable at this point
because it feels increasingly
like not i mean we i say this is a
person leading a company
out of california and into red america
where i've spent my entire life here
in la except for three years where i was
in cambridge massachusetts which was no
less blue and uh and now we are moving
to
you know dead red tennessee i mean
nashville is a blue area of tennessee
but
tennessee is a very red state uh and uh
and it feels increasing like the sides
are pulling apart do you think there's
any coming back together
i hope so i'm very much an optimist and
so
i want to believe that we can come back
together and i'm hopeful that we can do
it
without having some type of major event
i think we saw glimpses of it
in the early days of the coronavirus
pandemic you saw
a little bit of the politics pushed away
i'm hopeful it doesn't take some
major moment or something
bad to happen before people start to
block politics out again
but i want to be optimistic and believe
that at the end of the day the good in
people will outweigh the bad
and that we can start focusing a little
bit more on everybody's good
instead of starting with what's wrong
with somebody when you first meet them
instead of maybe there's something about
this person i could like
how does your husband deal with all this
um he
is one of the most laid back patient
people i've ever encountered
i don't know that i could be married to
anyone literally anyone else
that could be more perfect for me he is
just so patient so supportive
and he works in politics as well so i
think he knew a little bit about what he
signed up for
probably not quite to the extent but he
really i think takes it one day at a
time sometimes it's frustrating for him
because
he wants to be able to be more
protective and fight back
and at the end of the day that can be
very challenging not to be in the middle
and pushing back when somebody's
attacking your wife
um but you know we take every day in
stride and
he's a person of deep faith as well i
think
that has really helped both of us get
through
even the most difficult days so what
triggered your decision to leave the
white house you mentioned that
uh you had family concerns and you want
to spend more time with the kids
uh you're going to go back into politics
here pretty soon it sounds like uh so
what what what triggered the decision to
to move on uh certainly we wanted to
move our family from dc
back to arkansas that was a big priority
for us for our kids to grow up there we
have family
in arkansas and friends there and
so that was a big piece of it and also
just wanting to
have that time have a break away from
the intensity of washington
being the white house press secretary is
a 24 7 all-consuming job
you have no control over your schedule
and so i really wanted some time to be
able to do that with my
family we wanted to move before the
school year started so my kids could
start
at their school in arkansas not move in
the middle of the year so that was sort
of a catalyst for doing it during the
summer
and we are so happy to be back home well
what was the
thing that you didn't expect most about
the white house what's the most
unexpected thing about
working there because obviously been
around politics your entire life i think
in part one of the biggest
surprises for a lot of us i think if you
look
back most people in an administration
very few people actually know who they
are not that many people knew who the
white house press secretary was
in previous administrations if you
weren't you know interested in politics
and maybe a political junkie and outside
of dc you get into
middle america nobody knew who the press
secretary was but in a trump
administration
everybody knew who you were you became
instantly recognizable you were
you know the punching bag for snl and
many other things and so
i think that level of celebrity status
in a way for better or worse to
not have any moment where you go
anywhere where people don't recognize
you
i think was something that a lot of us
were very surprised by
and even people who weren't necessarily
the public facing
members of the administration quickly
became household names
and i i think that was very new even for
those of us who'd grown up in politics i
mean
again most people don't know who a lot
of the staff are they know the principal
but not everybody else
and the trump administration everybody
became a household name very quickly
did anybody from hollywood ever reach
out to you and talk to you on a personal
level or was it just okay we're gonna
cast whoever we can is this person to
make fun of them
you saw a lot of that obviously nobody
ever reached out to say anything nice
there were a few hollywood actors who've
said quite a few mean things
including one who encouraged people to
kidnap my children so
no unfortunately we didn't get a lot
from any of the uh
hollywood elite class there are a few
conservatives you know jon voight and a
handful of others
um that reached out were very supportive
james woods but uh in terms of kind of
the
the mainstream hollywood nobody ever
contacted us for
anything positive anyway yes he talked
about the upside of traveling with the
president
uh what was that like when you were with
him a lot on air force one you were with
him overseas a lot
how were how were those trips uh they're
incredible i mean they get to travel
alongside the president and see the
world in that way
is remarkable um i went on every single
foreign trip the president took
from the day i entered the white house
until i left
and had a front row seat to history
watching him interact with world leaders
i got to sit at the table with kim
jong-un
president xi abe macron
and be in that room as negotiations are
happening as history is unfolding
is absolutely remarkable that must be
some interesting conversation to watch i
mean obviously we've seen uh president
trump speak in uh
various terms about his relationship
with with kim jong-un
what was that like um it was pretty
surreal
and um you know as we were walking into
the room
it was very tense so far the day had
been good this was the very first summit
in singapore
and i think i'm going to kind of lighten
it up a little bit and i make a joke to
mike pompeo and i turned to him i said
hey mike thinking this will kind of like
relax
me mostly and bring the temperature down
i said so
um am i the only person in the room who
either hasn't killed someone or
ordered somebody to be killed and i kind
of laugh and he looks around the room
and he's like no you're the only one
i saw that going differently so okay i
was like well that wasn't exactly what i
was thinking you were gonna say
um but it was surreal but the president
was masterful
in that back and forth of bringing in
topics that he
knew were of interest to kim whether it
was sports and nba basketball
or and then being able to transition
from
something you know in a way so
meaningless to talking about
denuclearization for a country
and watching him kind of do that back
and forth was
absolutely incredible what do you think
is the thing that people get the most
wrong about president trump
is that he's somebody who doesn't love
the country and isn't actually
fighting to make it better i think that
not
knowing that misses who he really is
so how did you navigate all the various
personalities you know a lot of turnover
inside the trump administration we had a
secretary of state and then we had
another secretary of state we've had
a couple of secretaries of defense uh
and uh when they come in they are
greeted very often with warm words when
they leave
less often are they greeted with warm
words uh so so what was it like trying
to handle all those personalities
i think in some ways growing up in
both kind of church work and politics we
used to have kind of a joke in our
family that they're very similar
in that we take everybody the church
accepts everyone in politics you're
constantly trying to build a bigger base
so you take everybody
i was exposed to a lot of different
personalities
growing up in both of those environments
and so learned how to work with a
variety of different people
particularly as i grew and started doing
campaign work all over the country
or constantly interacting with such
a unique cast of characters and having
that background i think
put me in a good position to work with a
lot of different personalities in the
white house
i'm pretty upfront about where i'm on a
particular issue i don't play games i'm
very direct
and i think having that kind of
relationship i wasn't trying to go
behind anybody's back
i wasn't driving my own agenda i was
there to serve
the country and help the president and
not trying to play
all the different sides i think made a
big difference for me so president trump
talks a lot about what he's gotten under
in his first term and
agreed a lot of it's been very good not
a lot talked about
in terms of what he's going to do in his
second term so what do you think a trump
second term
looks like other than sort of more of
the same in terms of tax cuts or
deregulation
i certainly think those will be big
pieces i know he'd like to see
additional tax cuts deregulation is
probably one of the things that has been
most effective for the economy under the
first term that you don't hear a lot of
talk about so i think that he'll
continue
aggressively on that front i think trade
is going to be a major part of the
president's
second term is really trying to focus on
getting rid of the big trade imbalances
that we have with other countries it's a
huge personal priority for the president
i think it will continue to be
um top of mind for him in a second term
i think infrastructure is one
that is something the president actually
really
loves and enjoys and wants to see i mean
he's a builder well we need more
infrastructure
yeah infrastructure week always went so
well i don't know why we didn't do it
every week but i do think
that it's something that is personally
important to him
and i think that will certainly be
another thing that he really wants to
see happen
because it's always talked about and it
just keeps getting kicked down the road
and nobody ever really does anything
that has
a lasting impact i think that's
something that for him
personally he wants to see happen
prescription drugs is another
big area that he has personally invested
in and wants to see
so those are some of i think kind of the
you know 100 000 foot view areas that he
will want to focus on in a second term
one of the areas of highest controversy
obviously for the president has been
a lot of the public relations
surrounding coveted so there's been a
lot of talk about
why he let bob woodward anywhere within
a 100 foot radius
of the white house uh there's been a lot
of talk about uh his personal handling
of his commentary surrounding
covet i think a lot of that's been
unfair in the sense that nobody had a
handle on
what exactly was going on with kobet all
the way through february joe biden was
holding rallies in
early march uh eduardo coleman didn't
shut down the state of new york until
late march and all the rest but what do
you think that the administration could
have done better and what should they do
better with regard to
their messaging around covet well i
think they should talk about the things
that they did right
um and stop trying to defend and just
focus on like getting us
through you know
he i think made some very early
decisions that were very
important um certainly stopping travel
from china was a key
part and something that he talks about
frequently particularly given the fact
that democrats were attacking him for
that so there were some things they did
early on
that i think were very important they
should remind people of that but
now let's move forward let's figure out
how what we
what it looks like on the back end i
think they should focus on
where we're going how we're coming out
of it and not try to spend
so much time just from a purely
messaging perspective
so much time on everything that maybe
didn't go right and focus
on all of the things that they're going
to do moving forward and shift the
narrative
away and take that away from the
democrats that's what i would do if
i had the ability to to kind of shape
that message so do we need more on
teleprompter trump or less on
teleprompter trump
because you know i i'll be honest every
time he gets on teleprompter and reads a
speech it's not as high energy as it is
when he's doing a comedy rally
but at the same time it is a lot more on
message he gave a speech last week about
american history and patriotic education
that i thought was absolutely phenomenal
um i think many of his best moments have
been these teleprompters whether it's a
state of the union address that's really
well planned or whether it is his speech
in eastern europe about the nature of
western civilization seems like a lot of
what he says
on teleprompters is quite excellent uh
and uh
and some of what he says that is off
teleprompter is entertaining
do we need more on teleprompter trump
less on teleprompter trump
i think he has to have that balance i
think if we had only teleprompter trump
he wouldn't have won in 16
because some of that energy and
that personality that you see come
through
in those rally moments is what makes
people love donald trump because at the
end of the day
it's still very heavy about personality
and if you take all that away from him i
i don't think that's a good place for
him to be in but i
don't disagree that some of his biggest
moments
and best speeches are those teleprompter
speeches but one thing that i think
people
don't realize is how involved the
president is
in crafting those words and that
i think his team and speechwriting team
does such an excellent job
of capturing what the president's policy
is
and putting it in such a beautiful way
when he gives those big speeches
but the president's very involved you
know the classic
sharpie marker changes that you'll see
right up until the moment he steps on
stage he may be making edits to those
speeches so
i think they're both important i think
you have to have a good balance
i wouldn't want to see them try to strip
away all of the personality of donald
trump and put him on a teleprompter
one that's just not any fun i don't
think anybody wants to see
that all the time but i do think as you
go into these final days
a few of those big speeches that really
drive home his message
in such a clear and concise way will be
important and good for him to do
all right i'm going to ask sarah
huckabee sanders a few final questions
starting with whether president trump
really knows a lot about policy or
whether he really does not
and also about her own political
viewpoints and she's been spokesperson
for trump what are her political
viewpoints
if you'd like to hear sarah's answers
you have to be a daily wire member go to
dailywire.com click subscribe you can
hear the rest of our conversation there
well sarah huckabee sanders thank you so
much for stopping by it's been a
pleasure and i hope this is well
more welcoming than the red hen
certainly thanks so much for having me
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowski
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva title
graphics are by cynthia angulo
the ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20.